[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants au sport le zoo frau
avez vous été sage est-ce que nounours a
été sage que nous voulons pour le trou
gros qu'aucun de nounours va vite voir
pimprenelle et nicolas au lieu de faire
le perroquet ou que peu trop tu es
d'humeur joyeuse mais ne veille pas trop
tard bonsoir ruban ou pro vous alors à
cou rouge où les enfants n'étaient pas
de bruit de fond n'est pas donc trop
lourd qu'il a faim c'est très amusant
non
nicolas apporte un panier et une balle
près et le trou où cette étudiante
difficiel au bourget
[Musique]
sa valeur les paniers voilà une petite
pâle pour monsieur nono
alors j'ai commencé chez moi elle
commence à 4 bien on se met à trois
pales à 2 et 3 et puis on jette là bas
en essayant qu'à placer dans le panier
en europe on consulte le plus beau jeu
mais bon tu te prends non non non chez
moi mais et le public à brève je vais
encore être le dernier à l'or au cou et
[Musique]
à côté chez moi là à nicollin n'a pas
encore joué a pas atteint je les mister
du premier cours c'est pas mal mais tu
vas pas comme je lance en furent pour
lui mieux
[Musique]
n'est ce pas le bagne je souhaite qu'ils
font il n'y avait pas trois pattes
le battu qui s'est tu triches non non
c'est pas moi à moi de jouer moi c'est
moi je voi pedro en trop mais oui la
balle elle a roulé par terre elle est
allée se coucher car elle est fatiguée
allons leur enfant au dodo
sinon je vais perdre mon départ que
marchand de sable
on
mo
[Musique]
on est couché avoue que quand même
truche et nommé un petit peu bûcheron
aux petits cochons ne ferons plus dit
sinon demain on va au cirque avec papa
et maman doivent faire a dit que je
pouvais y aller parce que je suis guéri
peut-être bien que j'attrape rem aussi
une bonne maladie a buzzé vous bien le
temps aux gets 1 le lit mineur
comme lui je ne connais ni nicolas
pimprenelle alors les enfants
j'espère que vous vous êtes bien amusé
et aussi que vous avez joué plus
sagement que nounours ah te voilà gros
farceur ou autre ou allons en route
bonne nuit des enfants faites de beaux
rêves
à demain
un peu plus haut
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]